less than half of all children are doing  the recommended 60 minutes or more of  activity each day while around a fifth  of adults are doing less than 30 minutes  of physical activity per week  our local areas though provide many  opportunities to be active  whether it's in our playing pitches  along our coastlines at our leisure  centres in our parks and in our  woodlands  however not everyone can access these  easily  not everyone feels safe using them or is  able to afford membership fees  we want to remove some of these barriers  to create equal opportunities for all my  matter a person's age ability income or  where they live